declaro el carnaval de la Democracia el
carnaval de Río de Janeiro abierto
[Aplausos]
así el rey momo personaje principal del
carnaval dio inicio al más famoso del
mundo del de Río de Janeiro
tras dos años con restricciones debido a
la pandemia de covid-19 este 2023 los
cariocas han vuelto con toda
[Música]
con los cuerpos llenos de purpurina
disfraces coloridos y mucha Samba en la
ciudad de maravillosa también celebran
otra importante Victoria para muchos la
salida del ultraderechista Jair
bolsonaro del poder
[Música]
este año los organizadores del evento
han intentado poner en relieve el papel
de los ciudadanos afro protagonistas
indiscutibles de la fiesta y maestros de
los ritmos de la Samba
desde el viernes en la noche hasta el 25
de febrero el sambódromo y las calles de
Río de Janeiro estarán inundados por
música y gente hasta el amanecer una
fiesta por la que gente de todo el mundo
se ha desplazado hasta la ciudad
brasileña somos dos gays franceses
franceses en Río estoy disfrutando de la
vida hagamos este país amamos a las
mujeres es increíble Gracias río creo
que es uno de los mejores días de
nuestras vidas
[Música]
Ríos increíblemente bonito la naturaleza
la diversidad de barrios el carnaval es
una locura
la alcaldía carioca Calcula que recibirá
cientos de miles de personas durante el
carnaval buenas noticias para la
economía de la ciudad que se espera que
recaude cerca de mil millones de dólares
tras más de una semana de bailes y
felicidad